la gca fier du billet en dire j'ai fait
une cache ici
mamadou diop un lecteur dvd et à une
liasse de billets qui a dit que l'argent
n'avait pas d'odeur pour cette femelle
malinoise du groupe d'investigation
cynophile
il en a une sont donc fléchettes
aujourd'hui en pleine séance
d'entraînement avec david son maître
cela laisse paris en initiative en
premier celle qui fait sens sa recherche
d'odeurs en premier après si elle a des
difficultés ou s'il ya des endroits où
on ne va pas générer en trop ou à deux
dans quelle zone à douala la chaîne
tourne quelques secondes flair et marque
la position voilà donc à un marquage à
celle ci parce que la charge est à mi
hauteur vraiment pas touchés donc voilà
donc ce qu'elle a découvert deux sous le
nom sous le lecteur dvd cd billets un
travail sur le maître mais un jeu pour
le chien comme motivation fléchettes à
son doudou appelé boudin c'est l'objet
c'est ont joué je ne suis pas touché
c'est son goût et ses sports on lui a
appris à mémoriser l'odeur du billet est
l carrière quand on cherche le biais à
cherche-t-on jouer donc l assimiler ce
qu'on appelle ce bouddha l'odeur du
billet à la fin la récompense caresser
marques d'affection sont nécessaires
pour stimuler l'animal autre élément
indispensable la complémentarité
ici on parle de mariage chaque mètre est
indissociable de son chien pour une
meilleure lecture de l'animal c'est
spécifique à la galerie un chien est
attribué à m pendant toute sa carrière
aucun des collectes mon collègue maîtres
chiens si le programme est chiant pour
travailler moi je prendrais pas les
siens pourraient travailler
une complicité qui dure environ huit ans
et la durée moyenne de la carrière d'un
chien qui commence à l'âge d'un an et
demi une histoire d'amour qui ne
s'arrête pas à la retraite de l'animal
car les maîtres ont toujours la
possibilité de racheter leurs chiens
c'est quand vous arrivez à gramat vous
avez un test un test psychologique pour
vous attribuer un chercheur fonction
votre caractère
donc après avoir passé ces tests là on
vous dit tel chien sera mieux pour vous
que telle ou prochain c'est pas des
outils de travail
voilà c'est cdc les chiens comme ça peut
être votre chien de compagnie vous en
occuper tout le temps fort mais
également à la recherche d'armes
fléchettes intervient sur tout type
d'intervention
acquisition patrouille huit chiens sont
présents dans cette brigade qui
travaillent dans toute l'île de france
il y à 7 ans davy de mener deux
opérations par semaine aujourd'hui il en
réalise en moyenne deux par jour